[Applause]
[Music]
this latest protest organized by
opponents of President Daniel tiga
turned violent almost immediately as
protesters approached riot police in the
capital Managua on Saturday police fired
tear gas rubber bullets and stun
grenades known as flash bangs one of
these senior commanders grabbed one of
those flash bangs and throw it directly
on my forehead and it exploded and that
got me disoriented and I passed out mass
protests started in April last year at
first Nicaraguans demanded Social
Security reform then their demands grew
into a movement against Ortega and the
government over the past 17 months at
least 300 Nicaraguans have been killed
and tens of thousands have fled the
country more than a hundred political
prisoners are in jail as a mother I feel
uncomfortable because freedom is freedom
of expression - we have the right as a
country to express ourselves we have the
right to speak up but here we're held
captive they don't let us speak freely
Ortega has described his opponents as
violent terrorists inciting a coup
against him since the crisis began a
government crackdown has targeted human
rights groups journalists and activists
day we are marching in memory of mat
Romero the young man who was murdered on
September 27 by sniper when he merely
exercised his right to peaceful protest
we are marching for political prisoners
there are more than 120 political
prisoners who are still in prison the
government bans unauthorised protests
but rallies like this show that ortigas
opponents are in no mood to give up on
their demand for change victoria Gaytan
b al jazeera